nicolas mi ha fregato la domanda era la
domanda che volevo farvi i cercatori di
felicità la prima domanda che volevo
farvi ma quanti di voi cercano la
felicità al temo la mano quanti sono
alla ricerca della felicità in questa
stanza e quanti l'hanno trovata ed è una
platea selezionata platea del ted è un
ottimo platea non parte questo saremo
felici lo stesso ok
vorrei partito vorrei portarvi a fare un
viaggio all'interno delle nostre scuole
il porto con me perché a me capita di
viaggiare nelle scuole del trevigiano e
del castellanese e la prima domanda che
faccio agli studenti è ma gli adulti coi
quali siete in contatto le persone
grandi che che incontrate secondo voi
sono vivi posti limitano a sopravvivere
intendendo per vivi hanno gli occhi che
gli brillano sono entusiasti hanno
voglia di fare o si limitano
semplicemente al tran tran alla routine
il dato che noi abbiamo è che il 70 per
cento di noi adulti si limita al suo
tran tran
quindi è vero che ci sono 7 miliardi e
500 milioni di ricercatori di felicità
nel mondo più o meno penso che siano
tutti però di questi 7 scusate 7
miliardi di questi sette miliardi
non tanti provano la felicità il 70 per
cento si trova insoddisfatto pensate a
che consumo di risorse abbiamo nel
pianeta per la felicità eppure c'è
un'insoddisfazione di base le persone
sopravvivono ma non vivono mi sono
chiesto se era veramente così ho provato
a cercare degli degli studi che mi
dessero un indicazione e ho scoperto che
i neuroscienziati siamo carenti di tante
cose ma ce n'è una che abbiamo
tantissimo
sapete quanti pensieri facciamo in una
giornata mediamente provate a sparare
10.000 20.000 facciamo mediamente 60 mi
dai 60 ai 70 mila pensieri ogni giorno
l'anno misurato di questi pensieri
quanti ne abbiamo pensato il giorno
prima
95 per cento di quello che abbiamo
pensato abbiamo già pensato il giorno
prima a me sembra un po noiosa la cosa
di questi l'ottanta per cento solo
pensieri invalidanti su di noi
sugli altri allora la sensazione che mi
dà e di vivere in una palude senza
possibilità di ricambio con un 80 per
cento di materiale che immateriale tutto
sommato a del quale potremo fare
volentieri a meno
come ha origine tutto questo l'ipotesi è
questa che voglio fare insieme a voi c'è
un bambino che ha un grandissimo bisogno
l'essere umano di base a un grandissimo
bisogno di informazioni ha bisogno di
conoscere come noi ci procuriamo le
informazioni facciamo un movimento la
nostra attenzione a un movimento e va da
noi verso il mondo per conoscerlo lì
dove l'attenzione si appoggia noi
conosciamo
ad esempio in questo momento per
conoscervi io ho bisogno di appoggiare
l'attenzione su di voi e per conoscere
quello che sto dicendo per capirmi voi
avete bisogno di appoggiare l'attenzione
su di me quindi questo bimbo nasce
cresce con un'attenzione che è
proiettata tocca verso il mondo esterno
sente ma è sempre qualcosa che arriva da
fuori busta ma è sempre qualcosa che
arriva da fuori movimento
dell'attenzione proprio questo dà dentro
verso fuori per conoscere il mondo
in questo bambino crescendo fa tutta una
serie di esperienze ad esempio potrebbe
correre e potrebbe anche cadere
magari quando cadde arriva la nonna lo
prende braccio lo coccola e riprende a
cadere ma potrebbe anche succedere
esperienze che mi sono capitarmi è
capitato di sentire che papà è di fretta
dice
sento che ca di non correre cade e cosa
dice te l'avevo detto stessa esperienza
per un'esperienza diversa nel secondo
caso forse è meglio non fare il nostro
ragazzo studente nel nostro giovane
studente potrebbe alzare la mano con
entusiasmo e l'insegnante rispondere a
questo entusiasmo felice che ci sia un
ragazzo che finalmente ha piacere di
imparare
oppure potrebbe pensare uff ancora
un'altra domanda da questo qui ma cosa
vuole la classe potrebbe vedere lui come
un esempio che bello che è sempre
entusiasta e vuole conoscere
oppure potrebbe vederlo come un
secchione
capita a tutti è capitato che stesse
piangendo quando ero piccolino e
qualcuno ti ha detto non piangere che
sei grande e allora tu ti senti grani ha
stretto i denti e fatto una fatica
bestia per trattenere il pianto è però
adesso sei grande e quindi avendo to 5
anni e sei grande prendi il trapano per
fare un buco nel muro e arriva qualcuno
che ti dice sei piccolo sono grande sono
piccolo e capitato di assistere a una
cosa interessante una mamma che diceva
suo figlio non urlare
c'è qualcosa di contraddittorio
oppure che le dò mai per il tuo bene
cioè io ti faccio male ma per il tuo
bene allora voi capite che in queste
crescere in questo contesto potrebbe
generare in qualcuno la sensazione che è
meglio non fare o con la confusione a un
certo punto uno non sa cosa fare è
l'espressione della persona
dell'individuo si va progressivamente a
chiudere ma anche andando tutto bene
potrebbe essere che la persona manchi di
qualcosa ma anche di qualche
informazione sente che manca qualcosa ma
non sa dove cercarla e dove andare a
cercarla se x tutta la vita ha guardato
da dentro verso fuori andrà verso
l'esterno
nessuno gli ha insegnato che c'è un
componente fondamentale
e che viene a mancare nottate
dall'immagine noi abbiamo conosciuto il
mondo esterno
appoggiando l'attenzione fuori ma quasi
mai e quasi nessuno e forse nessuno ci
ha insegnato appoggiare l'attenzione su
noi stessi
questo è il punto decisivo se noi
vogliamo conquistare la felicità abbiamo
quanto meno bisogno di un equilibrio di
informazione tanta informazione utile
che proviene dal mondo esterno
tanta informazione utile che proviene
dall ascoltare noi stessi portare un po
di più l'attenzione su di noi
chiedersi ad esempio cosa voglio forse
il signore della prima fila della
seconda in questo momento ha fatto tutta
la notte in ospedale magari ha solo però
tiene gli occhi aperti per educazione ma
cosa vorrebbe lui cosa sento io in
questo momento in questo istante quasi
mai ci facciamo queste domande di che
cosa ho bisogno veramente in questo
momento usando ancora di più chi sono io
in questo momento potremmo semplicemente
ascoltare un sussurro che ci viene da
2500 anni fa dall oracolo di delfi che
ci invita a fare una cosa non è un
sussurro lui ce lo dice in modalità
imperativa conosci te stesso
iniziando ad ascoltarci quello che
succede è che si genera in noi un
progressivo senso di felicità perché
iniziamo ad appropriarci della nostra
vita sempre di più entusiasmo un tipo
ottimismo voglia di fare e sempre di più
ha luogo la felicità
vorrei concludere raccontando
raccontandovi una storia e sono un papà
e un bambino che sono all'interno di un
treno
il papa sta tentando di leggere una
rivista e il bambino vuole l'attenzione
del papa e quindi di chiedere da quant'è
che arriviamo papa e dopo tra 45 minuti
papa cos'è quella cosa bella lì fuori e
il papa che vorrebbe leggere la rivista
un certo punto cerca una stretta gemma
strappa la pagina un foglio della della
rivista che aveva l'immagine della terra
la fanta in tanti pezzettini e dice il
figlio figlio mio
adesso divertiti a ricostruire la terra
tieni qui lo scotch portato dal lavoro
con me adesso ricostruisce l'immagine
della terra e lui tira un sospiro di
sollievo dice adesso almeno per mezz'ora
papà e mio figlio mi lascerà in pace
potrà leggere in pace la rivista come
spesso accade coi bambini cosa succede
papa dopo cinque minuti ho finito come
il fatto che gli ho mio è impossibile
che tu abbia finito ed è stato molto
semplice in realtà dietro alla pagina
della terra c'era un uomo ho ricostruito
l'uomo e la terra
se aggiustata da sola grazie